the house will be in order
the chair lays before the house a
communications from the speaker
the speaker's rooms washington dc
january 11th 2020 2021
i hereby appoint the honorable debbie
dingle to act as speaker pro tempore
on this day signed nancy pelosi speaker
of the house of representatives
the prayer will be offered by chaplain
kibben
would you pray with me
merciful god we enter these chambers
with a sense both of uncertainty and of
indignation
the events of last week the destruction
the damage and the deaths of our fellow
americans are deeply disturbing
the seeds of discontent were sown across
our country and we have reaped the
whirlwind
almighty god speak into this storm
allow your holy spirit to descend upon
the chaos
and minister to our hearts still our
fears
that we would remain firm in our resolve
still our anger that we would yield
ourselves to your gracious
design for this nation
lord vindicate your intent for us to
serve as representatives not just of our
districts but of your will
your love lord and yours forever we pray
do not abandon the work of your hands
and as the spirit moves among us inspire
us again with your purpose
stir in us anew the desire to serve you
well and faithfully
as we seek to serve this divided country
us to hear the words of your mouth and
praise you with our lives this day
and in the days to come for we pray
these things in the strength of your
holy name
amen amen
pursuant to section 5a 1a
of house resolution 8 the journal of the
last day's proceedings
is approved the pledge of allegiance
will be led by the gentlewoman from
california
ms brownlee
the chair lays before the house a
communication
the honorable the speaker house of
representatives madam
i hereby submit my resignation as
sergeant-at-arms of the u.s house of
representatives
it has been an honor to serve signed
very respectfully
paul d irving sergeant-at-arms
without objection the resignation is
accepted
pursuant to the provisions of section
208
a of the legislative reorganization act
of 1946 the chair appoints timothy
paul blodgett of the state of new york
to act
as and to exercise the duties of
sergeant of arms of the house of
representatives
effective today
oh right there without objection
the chair will now administer the oath
of office
please raise your right hand do you
solemnly swear that you will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
that you will bear true faith and
allegiance
to the same that you take this
obligation
freely without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion and that you will
well and faithfully discharge the duties
of the office
on which you are about to enter so help
you god
congratulations
[Applause]
uh without objection the clerk lays
before the house
the following resolution
house resolution 22 resolution electing
a member to a certain standing committee
of the house of representatives
without objection the resolution is
adopted and a motion to reconsider
is laid upon the table
without objection the chair lays before
the house
the fouling resolution house resolution
23
resolution electing a member to a
certain standing committee of the house
of representatives
without objection the resolution is
adopted
and a motion to reconsider is laid upon
the table for what purpose
does the gentleman from maryland seek
recognition
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent
that the committee on the judiciary
be discharged from further consideration
of hres
21 and asked for its immediate
consideration in the house
the clerk will report the title of the
resolution
house resolution 21 resolution calling
on vice president michael r
pence to convene and mobilize the
principal officers of the executive
departments of the cabinet to activate
section 4
of the 25th amendment to declare
president donald j trump incapable of
executing the duties of his office
and to immediately exercise powers as
acting president
what purpose does the gentleman from
west virginia rise i object
objection is heard pursuant to section 5
a
1b of the house resolution 8
the house stands adjourned to 9 a.m
tomorrow
you